there's a beautiful song that Stephen  Sondheim wrote from Meryl Streep called  she'll be back for the character of the  witch and we all realized myself Stephen  Sondheim Meryl Streep James Lepine  realized actually the film was stronger  without it and so we made the very  difficult decision to let it go but one  of the joys of what we have here today  is that you get to see it as it was  originally placed in the film so enjoy  she'll be back next to me who is he  she'll be back she'll be back  Jesus ooh she just thinks she'll be free  we shall see free is one thing she never  will be every place that she goes every  face every Rose everything that she does  she'll remember what was and you wanna  come home she'll be back you'll be back  if there's one thing I know you'll be  back she'll be back  she'll be back she's just eager to grow  she's just young by tomorrow some more  as long as it takes let her go let her  make her mistakes